[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia mi
nombre es álvaro cordero este 23 de
agosto se cumple el 80 aniversario del
inicio de la mayor batalla en la
historia de la humanidad la de
stalingrado este episodio enfrentó a la
alemania nazi contra la unión soviética
y se convirtió en el punto de inflexión
de la segunda guerra mundial ya que tras
la derrota alemana el ejército nazi pasó
a la defensiva hasta su colapso
definitivo en 1945 en france 24
repasamos este acontecimiento histórico
la batalla de stalingrado se da en el
contexto de la invasión nazi a la unión
soviética aunque ambos países habían
firmado un pacto de no agresión
previamente adolf hitler decidió
declarar la guerra por sorpresa en junio
de 1941 invadiendo esta nación por tres
frentes que pretendían hacerse con
leningrado moscú y kiev una operación
que permitió capturar vastas extensiones
de tierra en unas semanas y a cientos de
miles de soldados soviéticos sin embargo
tres ciudades solo fue capturada kiev la
gran extensión que tenía la urss y el
duro otoño e invierno en esta nación
hicieron que la guerra relámpago nazi no
fuera tan efectiva es por ello que
hitler decidió cambiar de estrategia y
dirigir su fortaleza hacia el sur su
objetivo inicial era llegar hasta el
cáucaso para poder abastecerse de los
pozos petroleros de la zona un
combustible fundamental para alemania si
quería continuar con la guerra pero a
mitad de camino de este propósito estaba
la ciudad de stalingrado actualmente
conocida como volvo grave un objetivo
sin tanta importancia estratégica que
por el contrario para hilder se
convirtió en prioritario el líder alemán
consideraba que si sus tropas se hacían
con la ciudad que llevaba el nombre de
stalin el golpe moral sería definitivo
es por ello que dividió a sus tropas en
dos una avanzada iría hacia el cáucaso
mientras que la otra intentaría tomar
stalingrado una decisión cuestionada por
el alto mando alemán
stalin aceptó el desafío y blindó
stalingrado con miles de soldados
soviéticos y una orden de resistencia
ante todo
el objetivo del líder de la urss era que
bajo ningún concepto sus tropas se
rindieran y emitió la orden de ni un
paso atrás un dictamen que castigaba con
la muerte a todos los soldados
soviéticos que desertaran los bombardeos
y ofensivas alemanas hicieron que una
media de unos 4000 soviéticos
fallecieran cada día durante las
primeras semanas una situación que sin
embargo no aplacó la resistencia de la
ciudad
al frente de toda la defensa estaba el
mariscal zhúkov quien se encargó de que
los alemanes se vieran obligados a ir
tomando calle por calle para avanzar en
medio de una guerra total stalingrado se
convirtió en un esqueleto de escombros
que favoreció la aparición de una guerra
de guerrillas urbana y el uso de
francotiradores cuyo objetivo era
asesinar a altos mandos nazis y
dinamitar la moral de los soldados que
estaban las 24 horas en tensión
pero a pesar de la tenaz resistencia
soviética los alemanes se hicieron con
más del 70 por ciento de la ciudad en
unos meses haciendo pensar que de forma
irremediable stalingrado caería en manos
nazis no obstante el costo para los
alemanes estaba siendo muy alto los
nazis veían que capturar una calle
tomaba cientos de vidas y las
condiciones cada vez más extremas del
clima hicieron que las penurias se
multiplicarán ya que tuvieron que
soportar temperaturas de hasta menos 40
grados centígrados y apenas recibían
comida
una situación que propició que en
noviembre de 1942 los soviéticos
desarrollaran la operación urano
conscientes de que las tropas que
rodeaban stalingrado no eran alemanas
sino que eran rumanas e italianas mal
equipadas concentraron hasta un millón
setecientos mil soldados que cruzaron
las líneas enemigas para formar un cerco
en torno al ejército nazi una estrategia
que encerró a más de 300.000 soldados
alemanes la desesperación alemana se
hizo evidente a partir de ese momento
miles de soldados comenzaron a morir por
frío enfermedades o hambre e incluso
algunos se suicidaban ante la
imposibilidad de regresar a casa
los intentos alemanes de rescate fueron
un fracaso y a pesar de la negativa de
hilder para rendirse el mariscal
friedrick paulus capítulo en febrero de
1943 los soviéticos tomaron como presos
a 90.000 soldados alemanes de los cuales
sólo 6000 volverían a casa tras pasar
por campos de trabajo en siberia
las cifras de esta batalla muestran la
crueldad de los combates hasta 800 mil
soldados alemanes y de sus aliados
fallecieron en esos meses algo que hay
que sumar a los más de mil 600 tanques
900 aviones y 6000 piezas de artillería
que fueron destruidos por su parte la
unión soviética perdió solo en esta
batalla a 1,5 millones de personas y
decenas de miles de tanques aviones y
piezas de artillería el fracaso de
stalingrado supuso un punto de inflexión
en la segunda guerra mundial y el inicio
del retroceso de la alemania nazi
hasta ese momento el ejército alemán
había llevado la iniciativa en todos los
frentes que había abierto pero su
estrepitosa derrota en stalingrado hizo
ver que su capacidad estaba limitada
desde ese momento la unión soviética
empezó a comandar varias ofensivas desde
el este mientras que por el oeste y el
sur los aliados comenzaron a desembarcar
en continente europeo y retomar
territorios una situación que terminaría
por forzar la derrota final de la
alemania nazi y el suicidio de adolf
hitler en abril de 1945 con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]